uh meantime let's talk more should we
about the government's latest plans for
the environment the Energy Secretary
Grant shops is joining us now um hello
to Mr Schatz thanks for joining us I
mean there's a lot to unpick in what you
are proposing today but one of the
things that will impact most on my
viewers is is what you're trying to do
about gas four in five homes are present
the heated by gas in the UK how are you
going to get them to switch to cleaner
electricity and other forms of energy
well that would be a process over a
period of time no one's being forced to
remove their gas from their home but we
do know that in the longer arm uh things
like mixing hydrogen into the gas
Network that doesn't involve people
doing anything at home you can do up to
about 20 of that is part of the solution
and increasing the use of things like
heat pumps most importantly things like
insulation of homes as well so there's a
lot of different ways in which homes
will move towards uh using energy
sources which are more reliable in green
over what period of time
uh over the next decade or two so
um for example
um you know we all know that electricity
can be a big way to decarbonize but we
also know these are big changes so as I
say this is not to sort of rip out your
boiler mode this is a transition over a
period of time to get to uh homes which
are heated in a different way and also
insulate it much better when we've made
massive progress on that we've gone from
just 14 1 4 of homes being improperly
insulated in 2010 to nearly half of
homes today 47 so we're we're making
rapid progress on that and we intend to
continue that part of the money I'm
announcing today okay how many heat
pumps have been installed so far
we're in the low numbers still hundreds
of thousands not the millions 42 000
wasn't it well I think that this didn't
see a number per year and the overall
number
24 to 2000 last year though wasn't it
over yeah that's right yeah not very
many is it
no and it's a program which is they sent
us at the beginning uh there are
technical issues that people are having
to to deal with in order to make the
switch over but we're extending a an
incentive scheme today which is 5 000
pounds uh when you install the heat pump
and what that does is helps to bring the
price down close to or even lower than
installing a regular conventional gas
boiler now recently we've seen a couple
of energy companies oxburths and British
gas offer uh boilers which
should say uh heat pumps which match the
price of boilers two and a half three
thousand pounds we're starting to see
that come into uh you know line and we
could see a lot more installs as a
result of that but it will take time
that's true and you acknowledge that
some people's bills can be significantly
higher when they get these heat pumps
installed
that's not quite as straightforward as
it sounds because one of the things that
you do need to do is make sure that we
insulate homes as well so today I
launched a Great British installation
program to make sure that we're uh
ensuring that homes are ready for heat
pumps and either way help to lower
people's bills so these things do have
to work in combination that's absolutely
true labor are not buying it at all
they're saying it's just reheated
policies and you're only doing it today
because you're being forced to because
of the deadline by the high court which
runs out tomorrow
legislative to get to Net Zero by 2050
it was asked under a conservative
government with the first country in the
world to do it we've made more progress
on this than any other industrialized uh
Nation
um so I just they would say that
wouldn't be such a thing but actually
today is a thousand pages of over 70
different policies in a lot of detail
both existing and quite aim sounding
things like you might say insulation but
also very Advanced things as well like
carbon capture utilization and storage
this country has a massive opportunity
to capture carbon and barrier under the
sea in the old old gas location engages
with that there isn't it um
um
talk to me about the UN Secretary
General Antonio Gutierrez he recently
urged all countries to bring forward
their Net Zero targets by a decade why
are we not doing that
yes sorry just on the early stages
you're right but this is a 20 billion
pound investment is not a small amount
of money we know that this does work and
it could be a massive export for Britain
as big as oil and gas it was itself
um so I think it's really important and
look in terms of you know bringing
forward and so on and so forth uh as I
said there's no other country that's
legislative I could personally I'm
personally accountable and it means that
I have to make sure that we deliver on
our agreements and we're doing it faster
we're doing the decarbonization faster
than anywhere else I want to do it in a
way that brings jobs to this country I
want to make sure that people have the
power and the energy they need both in
the short term and in the much longer
term this morning under the UK Fusion uh
facility here in Oxfordshire at Callum
uh where column where you know one day
we'd be reducing endless amounts of
energy very cheaply so we've got
short-term debts and long-term bets and
in doing so we're also clearing up RX as
well okay what Net Zero changes are you
making in your own home
well over the years I've done different
things for example fishing fitting solar
panels 12 years ago I've driven an EV
second TV electric vehicle and we've
done things just simple things like
turning down the boiler flow which is
one of the things that we were
recommending over uh Christmas included
double glazing and all of those types
and so you know we're trying to do the
Practical things I've got somebody and
we just surveyed the house to see
whether a heat pump would work in my
house as well you write and point out
that there are issues that mean that it
can't just be universally fitted so you
know gradually doing things I'm not sort
of some Eco warrior in this I just want
to try and save money on my energy bills
like everybody else
last year a private jet took off in the
UK on average every six minutes which
produces between 5 and 14 times more
carbon dioxide than commercial
commercial airlines
um you're going to penalize them
also I mean what I believe on all of
this stuff is need to find ways to not
stop ourselves from continuing to
develop as human beings but instead I'm
ways to be able to operate and do so
without harming uh you know the world
and our environment and actually
sustainable aviation fuel is the way to
do that I chair something called the jet
zero Council and the whole point of what
we're trying to do is get to what I call
you know guilt-free flying we want to be
able to have a world in which people can
fly and don't need to feel like it's
damaging the world now that's possible
even with the technology that we have
today with sustainable aviation fuel
what we want to do is take that even
further hydrogen in place we've got
aircraft in this country flying now as
test aircraft with hydrogen which
doesn't emit anything so there are ways
to get this job done and that's what I'm
focused on
we talk about guilt-free flying I mean
you're a Private Pilot do you do you
feel guilty when you're flying private
jets
oh well I don't fly just private jets
but I am a pilot I can say and I do fly
uh and you know just as when people jump
in their car uh you know that you're
looking for that transition that's
exactly what's happening in the aviation
sector one of the reasons I'm so Keen to
drive that forward or Pilot that old jet
zero a plan is to remove the carbon
aspect and that's gone through
technology I don't believe as a you know
human beings the answer to all of this
is to sort of withdraw from the world uh
just appear you know go back to caves or
something like that we've got to both
develop our economies and find ways to
make the planet safer and no country has
done more than britons do that we've
lowered our carbon faster than anybody
else okay we're almost time Secretary of
State we're almost out of time and I
wondered if I could just ask you quickly
about a story that is in the times this
morning uh my colleagues at the time was
getting a lot of grief from off gem who
are threatening
um to opt to slam them with unlimited
fines if they don't hand over all of the
evidence of British gas agents breaking
into customers homes what would you say
I'm pleased you've asked me about it
look is journalists in this country do
an incredible job of exposing problems
holding people like me and others to
account I would always be on the side of
freedom of our press off-gen who are a
regulator you need to fix the problems
that were uncovered and not be pursuing
threatening to pursue journalists who've
uncovered these things and would say
that the regulator should have been
binding itself shouldn't be pursuing the
journalists I can be as clear as you
like on this it is wrong for them to be
pursuing the journalists I would be very
disappointed to see them progress that
through the courts the journalists are
merely doing the job of uncovering
something that was absolutely should not
be going on and I had cracked down very
hard uh on that particular scavenge to
do the prepayment features I expect the
regulator to do the same job
okay my top tip for your team this
morning Mr Sharps is it's incredibly
echoey where you are and very difficult
to hear what you're saying at times they
might want to move you before you start
doing other interviews but thank you
very much indeed for taking the time to
join us